[Music]  it looks like a little beautiful peach  Jada pinkett-smith reveals she  rejuvenated her yoni it all went down on  her Facebook watch show red tabletop  Jada took her mom to a vitality Center  for vaginal rejuvenation treatments when  I tell you that I have my yoni is like a  16 year old I'm not kidding  the 46 year old actress says she  received treatments for her bladder  issues in the past which completely went  away after three treatments but it can  still be a little awkward for me it uh  it was a lot of confront I'm sitting  there I'm looking at you and we're  talking two out of ten women do have  like a happy time while they're getting  the treatment Jada has covered  reproductive health in her read table  talks before covering sex and pleasure  in a recent episode with her daughter  willow I definitely think that  especially women right now we need a  place where we can talk about real  things in a real way because it's  complicated times  [Music]